لا اله الا الله
يا الله ساعدنا
يا رب انا اسف على كل شيء يا رب
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تمكن من الخروج هذا الشاب بعد نحو عشر
ساعات من تحت الانقاض وتمكن من الخروج
لوحده يعني حاول ان يتسلل من بين الانقاض
ثم وصل الى خارج المبنى المدمر
[موسيقى]
المضرب الزلزال الثاني بطحنا فوق بعض ووعد
فينا البنايه وضليت انا بعد فتره لاحسنت
اتحرك يعني ضليتي ساعتين ثلاثه احسنت
اتحرك من مكاني كنت ما اعرف شو وضعي وكان
قدامي بنت وراي بنت وقدامي اخي شفت اخي
وخالي ومرت خالي وبنات خالي كمان شفتهم
كلياتهم كانوا قدامي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
كان بايدي الجوال كان عند خالي هو عنده
اخذته منه كان قريب علي احسنت افتح الجوال
احاول اطلع احاول اروح امشي ما احسنت اطلع
حالي ما احسنت احرك حالي ابدا بعد الساعه
ونص باكيت فاقد الامل كليا اني احسن اتحرك
او اطلع وما عندي ابدا اني احساس برجلي ما
كنت حاس فيها بقى انا ما اعرف انه اذا كنت
حاعيش ولا لا قلت بصور بشان اذا طلعوا
الجوال
وصيه ومات الكل ما ضلل حدا
يا الله